other news here at five o'clock nursing
mothers now have more protections at
work since the pump for nursing mothers
act went into effect just this past
Friday eight news now anchor Kirsten
Joyce connects with an expert who breaks
down what this means for all of us
the pump for nursing mothers act
originally passed in December of last
year as of April 28th it is now in
effect Andrea ippolito says it allows 25
percent of women in the workforce who
weren't previously covered to now have
access to certain protections it's a
very important piece of legislation that
gives women and folks that are pumping a
protected place to pump other than a
bathroom and it also allows them to have
protected time to pump and also that
they get paid for that time ipolito
works directly with pregnant mothers to
help with breastfeeding and support from
pregnancy to after birth returning to
the workforce and developing plans for
pumping mother she says are now relieved
they don't have to advocate for these
options but that they're now just part
of law the pump act will affect over 9
million women that previously were not
protected under prior legislations this
includes folks like teachers and nurses
is nurse practitioners Farm Workers
transportation workers computer
programmers doctors oh so many folks
that weren't protected in the prior
legislation she adds when our Workforce
lost millions of women during the pink
color recession of the pandemic this law
not only helps facilitate their return
but keeps them in the workforce